this is the epicenter of what has become
a major police investigation here on the
outskirts of Glasgow over the course of
this morning this is the home of Peter
Morrow the home of Nicholas sturgeon the
power couple in Scottish politics until
just last week we understand according
to one neighbor here that Nicholas
sturgeon left this property just after
eight o'clock this morning 20 minutes or
so before this police
Cordon was put up this tent was erected
of course that's usually reserved for
major police investigations let's give
you a census to the scale of this uh
inquiry and we'll walk down the street
of course there are a number of police
vehicles here and within sides the
occupants are not there the detectives
are there is the windows closed the
blinds are closed and the curtains too
the front room there is shielded by a
police barrier and within that blue tent
is where the evidence is being gathered
this is an investigation that is
centered on the snp's finances and its
fundraising uh discussions over the
course of the last couple of years here
in Scotland around alone that Peter
Morrell apparently gave to the SMP uh
over the course of the last couple of
years and also questions around 600
000 pounds of
finances that were raised for the cause
of a second Scottish independence
referendum well in the last hour or so
we can see the garage there of Peter
model the garage of Nicholas sturgeon it
is now closed but we can tell you that
there has been a hive of police activity
within that garage uh photos have been
taken items have been screened and
removed and I can also tell you that
within this blue tent here just behind
where these officers are standing there
is what appears to be a white vehicle so
what is within that tent well that is
what detectives are examining and all
the while Peter model the 58 year old
former chief executive of the SNP a man
who was at the Helm of the Scottish
national party for more than two decades
well he resigned just a number of weeks
ago after a huge controversy surrounding
membership numbers 30 000 members left
the SNP over the course of the last 18
months there were suggestions that the
party tried to cover up those dwindling
numbers and he resigned fairly suddenly
and it was a shock resignation at the
same time that his wife Nicholas
sturgeon Departed the highest office in
the land after 3 000 days at the top
Nicholas sturgeon was clear during
questions by Sky News in recent weeks
one of her final interviews in office
she was asked specifically whether she
or her husband had been interviewed as
part of this police investigation and
she said No at that point well that has
changed today Peter Morrow is no longer
in this house he is facing a barrage of
questions from detectives as this
investigation gathers pace